in the opening scene a man named
terenzio rushes into a brasilian airport
he is visibly panicking and is in a
hurry most people would think he is
missing a flight but the truth cannot be
further from that he asks the help desk
for any ticket to the west but finds out
the nearest one is two hours later still
he buys the ticket just for the sake of
crossing the terminal at the same
airport a famous influencer ines is
video chatting with a friend in new york
when suddenly she chokes and falls
unconscious inez is worried especially
since she cannot do anything to help her
outside people who are watching the tv
see that the tv reporters and live show
hosts have passed out in front of the
camera not just that but an entire
street of people are lying unconscious
on the ground the viewers think it must
be some kind of joke except for terenzio
who knows what is going on he says it is
time for him to act and rushes to the
terminal when a guard is distracted
tyrenzio snatches his gun and asks
everyone to get out of his way he rushes
to a flight that is about to take off to
moscow in a few minutes only some
passengers have boarded the flight when
he gets inside and holds everyone at
gunpoint the pilot is missing and the
co-pilot matthew doesn't want to help
the terrorists as they fight for the gun
a bullet hits matthew's palm and injures
him outside the passengers panic and the
flight attendant gabrielle tries to keep
them calm terenzio comes out of the
cockpit asking if there is a pilot on
board a woman named sylvie gets up
although she is only a retired
helicopter pilot under torenzio's order
she and matthew take off with all other
passengers the avionics are broken
because of the bullet and as a result no
one from the plane can contact anyone
outside when the plane is airborne
sylvie and matthew try their best to
reason with terenzio but the man remains
adamant he says that he is an officer
assigned to nato and knows something
that they don't upon being urged he
reveals that the rays of the sun have
become deadly starting the next day the
sunrise is going to kill everyone even
those who stay indoors this has already
started in eastern countries like japan
and korea and the plane will be the next
target if the sunrise catches up with
them matthew and sylvie do not believe
him and theorize that he is mentally ill
terenzio also acknowledges that he might
seem like an idiot but claims that he is
not matthew's hand is bleeding
profoundly which might cause a problem
in the long run one of the passengers
named laura is a home health nurse for
an old man with dementia she is the only
medical professional on board so she
takes the responsibility to help the
pilot they have no sewing kit to close
the wound so they use a hot knife
matthew screams in pain and the
passengers panic even more matthew knows
that if they start to protest everyone's
life will be in danger hence he tells
them that they will land at a different
location as per torenzio's wish before
continuing their way to the original
destination matthew hopes that the
fighter jets are coming to rescue them
since they were taken at gunpoint but
for some reason sylvie feels like
they're on their own a passenger named
ias has heard them talk about the sun
and is suspicious that the pilot is
lying to them suddenly an arab passenger
starts coughing and falls unconscious
ayaz pretends to be helping him and then
snatches terencio's gun in the process
tarenzio is locked inside the toilet at
iaz's order and matthew is asked to tell
the truth the pilot discloses they are
landing in iceland because terenzio
wanted to go somewhere west there the
police will arrest the terrorists and
the others will be let free he also
tells them about the sun and how
terenzio thinks it will kill people this
sends the passengers into a frenzy they
start recalling strange things that
happened before they boarded the flight
and are worried about their families
matthew calms everyone and takes the
responsibility to save them all as the
captain a while later he tries to land
in an airport in iceland but gets no
signal from traffic control when they
can see the ground close up they notice
several airplanes have crashed into each
other and people are running around they
finally register that terenzio was
telling the truth but since the runway
is blocked they cannot land the plane
only has enough fuel to fly a bit west
to scotland hence the captain decides to
do so and hope for the best he brings
torenzio out of the toilet so the man
can tell everyone what is going on he
discloses that he found out about the
sun by eavesdropping on his seniors
conversation he doesn't know why it is
happening or if it will stop anytime
soon all he knows is that if they want
to survive they will have to fly away
from the sunrise meanwhile the arab man
who passed out earlier is still on the
floor he has a hard time breathing and
is about to go into cardiac arrest with
his last breaths he says that he
swallowed diamonds the nurse laura tries
her best to pull the diamonds from his
ass i mean to save him but her attempts
go in vain at the same time they go
through an emergency landing in scotland
where matthew stops the plane seconds
away from hitting a wall they go outside
and their phones start chiming with
notifications from their loved ones the
internet is filled with news about
deadly sunlight half of the world has
died and the other half is waiting for
their death the airport is empty because
everyone who had the chance to run away
has fled and the others are hiding in
dark places hoping that it will protect
them however the news suggests that
people are dying even inside bunkers
suddenly they are approached by three
raf servicemen asking for help they only
have 45 minutes before sunrise so they
decide to collect important supplies and
fly west one of the passengers is an
aircraft engineer jacob he wants to go
back to his pregnant wife to save her
but for the overall safety of the
passengers he is asked to step back
after collecting supplies and filling
the airplane's tank they take off one
more time one of the servicemen is a
pilot and suggests they fly away from
the equator to avoid the sun catching up
to them faster their next stop is canada
where they will fuel up the airplane
again and fix the radio a while later
the internet is fixed and their phones
all begin to chime they receive the last
messages from their loved ones who have
already died in brussels then a man
finds an article saying that the cause
of the disaster is the sun's polarity
another passenger named horst is a
climate specialist and knows what a
sun's polarity means he explains that
every 11 years the sun's magnetic field
reverses but no one knows why it has no
significant effect on the world so not
much research has been done however over
the past few decades the intensity of
the reversal was growing weaker because
of this horst thinks the reversal has
become much more powerful in the other
direction if what he is saying is true
the earth is being blasted with gamma
rays everywhere the sun falls which is
why people are dying instantly they have
no way to prove the theory because the
scientists who published the article are
also probably all dead right then ias
finds out a news report saying that the
raf servicemen they picked up are
actually terrorists from afghanistan
they were arrested and were being
brought back to their country at the
airport outside one of them gets into an
argument and pushes the old man who has
dementia it causes his death
and gains the terrorist the passengers
disapproval being a terrorist is cool
but pushing old people dude sylvie tells
matthew about the news report and the
two decide to abandon the terrorists
when they land in canada a few minutes
later they land and have two hours
before sunrise several victims of the
sunlight lie around in the city the
terrorists are asked to look for repair
radio parts in the nearest shop they
agree but insist on taking gabrielle and
jacob with them the problem is that
jacob knows about the plan but not
gabrielle hence when they are in the
shop and jacob locks the terrorists in a
room gabrielle refuses to come with him
jacob doesn't waste any time trying to
convince her in the end he makes it to
the airport while being followed by the
terrorists but gabrielle is left back in
the city the airplane takes off without
her the terrorists follow it and are
able to hit a window with a bullet
fortunately for the passengers it only
creates a crack so if they maintain a
level altitude it will not break a
terminally ill kid named dominic is also
on the flight ayaz tries to chat with
him but his overprotective mother zara
asks the man to go away suddenly they
get a radio signal from someone in
hawaii the conversation is cut short but
they assume that some survivors are
staying in an underwater bunker which is
why they are alive matthew wants to
leave for hawaii as soon as possible but
silvie thinks going there because of an
unclear message would be stupid
meanwhile terenzio is furious that the
captain gets to make all the decisions
he protests and everyone comes to an
agreement that they will vote to make a
decision from now on just when things
start to calm down several alarms ring
at the same time indicating an aircraft
malfunction upon analyzing the problems
matthew learns that one of the
terrorists who was following the plane
earlier has somehow attached himself to
the landing gear if he remains there
they will not be able to land hence
matthew decides to fly as high as
possible so the temperature and lack of
oxygen will take him down however he
fails to consider the cracked window
because of the pressure difference it
breaks causing chaos inside the plane
things fly into the sky as the
passengers brace themselves for impact
matthew quickly brings the plane to a
lower altitude and jacob uses a wooden
board to close the window for some time
everyone calms down but dominic has
trouble breathing because his
respiratory tube flew away is thinks of
a plan and uses the oxygen pipe to make
a respiratory tube zara is thankful and
ashamed that she was mean to ayaz
earlier the captain tells everyone that
hawaii is no longer an option because
they will never reach there on time at
this altitude the most feasible option
would be to land in atu an alaskan
island moreover the turbulence wasn't
able to get rid of the hanging terrorist
this guy would be superman if he wasn't
you know a terrorist i as jacob and
terenzio go to the undercarriage and
make a hole on the plane's floor to get
a view of him torenzio uses his gun to
point into the dark but the criminal
pulls it and almost kills him luckily
ayaz comes to his rescue and shoots the
terrorist dead he becomes their hero for
a few minutes before the passengers find
out that he was the reason the arab
passenger died they bury his body back
in canada where a guy saw ayaz cut his
stomach open ayaz confesses he is a con
artist who was smuggling diamonds from
brussels to moscow the diamonds were
inside the arab man's body with his
consent but he died because he didn't
follow the panicking instructions on
hearing the confession some passengers
protest that ayas should be abandoned
like the terrorists but the overall vote
falls in ayaz's favor as a result he is
handcuffed in the avionics bay in the
following scene they land in alaska and
refill the tank again before taking off
once airborne the climatologist horst
discovers something strange the fruits
they picked up in canada taste like they
have no flavor he thinks it is because
the gamma rays are so intense that they
are remodeling the atomic structure of
the food the most concerning part is
that it decreases the nutritional value
of the food if this goes on they will
starve to death in a few weeks the
science in this movie is out of control
[ __ ] matthew acknowledges the danger
but claims that their primary concern
should be running away from the sun he
has started to lose control of himself
in the past few hours sylvia asks him to
take a rest but he yells at her which is
unlike his normal self the passengers
decide to force him to rest and bring
him outside the cockpit although annoyed
matthew promises to sleep for the next
few hours a while later they pick
another signal on the radio and hear two
parties talking but the group only hears
them say stara17
they soon figure out that the person
talking on the phone is a cosmonaut in
space they are shocked that someone like
that is alive but this also means he is
talking to the control room which is on
the earth with renewed hope for survival
they decide to go to nato headquarters
in brussels where it all began at this
rate they will have four hours after
they land in brussels until the sun
comes out hence they might find some
information about the secret bunker in
the headquarters with tarenzio's help
outside laura finds matthew unconscious
in the toilet it turns out that the
injury on his palm has been infected and
caused blood poisoning this is why he
had been acting the way he did earlier
to solve the problem they have to
amputate the infected tissue laura says
she can do the operation in brussels if
they manage to reach a hospital however
without matthew sylvie cannot land the
plane on her own the passengers beg her
since she is the closest thing to a
pilot they have but she knows that she
can only land a helicopter horst makes
her understand that if she doesn't take
initiative everyone is going to die
following that sylvia is made to watch a
few videos on how to land a plane
however when she has to actually do the
work she panics an aggressive turbulence
hits and everyone braces themselves for
the worst in the end they go through a
shaky landing but other than that both
the plane and the passengers are safe
everyone claps for sylvie and enjoys the
moment of achievement amidst the
disaster not wasting much time they
divide into three groups to do different
tasks two men stay at the airport to
refill the fuel zara laura and her group
bring matthew to the nearest hospital
while terenzio is and a man named rick
go to the nato headquarters at the
hospital they find numerous dead bodies
blocking hallways by the looks of it
people were informed about the deaths
before sunrise and were trying to save
their lives laura orders everyone to
ignore the chaos and focus on saving
matthew at the same time zara fills her
bags with medicine for her son and for
the others meanwhile at nato
headquarters tarenzio shows them the
conference room where he first heard
about the disaster they cannot go
through all the papers with the time
they have left so rick decides to see if
the surveillance footage has something
while he is away tyrenzio makes fun of
ayaz's turkish descent and the two get
into a fight nothing like racism at the
end of the world he accidentally hits
ayaz causing him to fall unconscious and
bleed heavily somewhere else rick finds
a recording of the officials talking
about a bunker under a dam in bulgaria
the place's name is stera17 the same
thing they heard on the radio a few
hours ago before he can go back to the
guys terenzio comes to him and tells him
that iez has already left rick sees
ayaz's body lying in a pool of blood on
the screen but is too scared to speak
half an hour before the sunrise everyone
boards the plane matthew is not in his
best state but feels better after the
surgery torenzio tells everyone that
ayaz drove away before them but they can
no longer wait for him to return with
heavy hearts they start the engines when
suddenly a car stops in front of the
plane and i ass comes out in the
following scene terenzio is being
handcuffed in the avionics bay sylvie
tells everyone that if the bulgaria plan
doesn't work they won't have enough fuel
or time to reach another destination
when they touch down everyone must be
ready because they will only have 20
minutes to drive to the location of the
bunker ayaz is in the toilet when
suddenly he gets a seizure it lasts only
for a few seconds and he thinks it is
because he has lost too much blood
however he refrains from telling the
others when he comes outside he is asked
what he wants to do with terenzio not
wanting to sentence him to death he
allows the guy to come with them to the
bunker a while later they land at a
bulgarian airport and separate into two
groups riding two different vehicles
sylvie drives the first car and leads
the way while ias drives the second one
on the way he gets a seizure again
causing them to crash the first car has
already driven far away and the group
has no way to keep up in the short time
at an intersection sylvie takes the
right turn and reaches a half open gate
a passenger tries touching it and is
sent flying because of the electricity
moreover it turns out that they have to
continue pressing a button for the gate
to stay open to redeem himself terenzio
offers to wait for the others while
sylvie and the group go inside before
leaving sylvie handcuffs him to the
stand so he won't betray them it also
confirms that he will only be free when
the other group arrives however ayaz and
the group take a left turn at the
intersection and reach a similar gate
from the other side of the dam they use
their clothes to climb up and beyond the
entrance in the end they all reached the
entrance to the bunker even though they
took different exits the passengers are
finally received by military men who
welcome them inside and affirm that they
are safe here terenzio is left alone
asking god for forgiveness as the sun
rises he stands facing it and asks it to
do its best in the end he is also killed
to know what happens to the surviving
passengers next watch the second part in
our new channel series recapped
thank you for watching